sometimes the little things illuminate
the big things i was on the east coast
last week and have to catch a bit of
msnbc's morning show morning joe it was
a great discussion about the american
dream as a new citizen something close
to my heart with david rubinstein who's
just written a book about it but at the
end joe scarborough took it in a more
political and polarizing direction trump
voters don't quote believe in america he
said it sounded to me like an outrageous
smear and i said so
on twitter
that prompted a furious reply from joe
he called me a liar i never said that i
would never say such a thing he raged
okay well that was pretty definitive
perhaps i misheard
so i replied that i would happily
withdraw my comment if i was wrong
let's check the tape i said
i assume they have the tape since it's
you know their show
but i never heard back
so we checked the tape and here it is
we've got a lot of work to do to
convince people the american dream is
still alive
well and and also
you see a lot of people who supported
certain candidates in 2016 and 2020 uh
not believing in america and and and
even getting to a point where they
attacked
the people's house the united states
congress
he absolutely said what i heard now he
may have meant to say something else but
he didn't
it came across as a casual smear against
millions of fellow americans and then he
called me a liar for pointing it out now
i don't want to make too big a deal of
this who cares about a little spat
between two people on tv but it
illustrates a bigger point one we should
be concerned about it shows how readily
they lie
and when that's applied to more
significant issues it's a real problem
for the country
on monday in the written house trial
this was the testimony from gage gross
croix shot by kyle rittenhouse
you were standing three to five feet
from him with your arms up in the air
he never fired right
correct it wasn't until you pointed your
gun at him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him that he fired
right
correct
and this is what was reported that night
by msnbc
rose kretz came across written house
after he had shot and killed joseph
rosenbaum and was about to kill anthony
huber
grosscrutz acknowledged that he was
armed with a pistol but says his hands
were raised when he was shot by
rittenhouse
except he didn't say that
at the top of their 7pm show that night
msnbc told its audience the exact
opposite of the truth
let's play it again back to back
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct grosscrutz acknowledged that he
was armed with a pistol but says his
hands were raised when he was shot by
rittenhouse
i mean i i don't think i've ever seen a
more blatant lie there's no way that's a
mistake that was msnbc deliberately
lying to its audience to advance its own
narrative its own ideological agenda
and when you lie so blatantly about an
incredibly high profile incident which
has the whole country on a knife edge
that's not a little lie it's a big lie
and it's now so common so casual in the
media it's making impossible for us to
have a shared conversation in this
country about the same set of facts
there's the real world and then there's
the fantasy world the made-up world the
world of lies invented by msnbc and cnn
and all the rest the world where russia
collusion was something trump did
instead of as we now know something the
clinton campaign did the world where the
covington kid was a racist provocateur
rather than a decent young man standing
firm against provocation the world of
russia bounties on american soldiers the
world where lab leak is a conspiracy
theory where jesse smollett was the
victim where the atlanta spa shooting
was anti-asian hate where black attacks
on asians are white supremacy where
officer sicknick was killed by a fire
extinguisher where hunter biden's laptop
was russian disinformation whether
migrant surge is seasonal where crt is
not taught in schools these are all lies
not mistakes not misunderstandings but
deliberate falsehoods pushed by the
media as propaganda
and when you see the scale of it the
audacity of it the fact that they never
own up to it or apologize for it or
correct it even when the facts prove
they're lying
or perhaps it's not trump voters joe
scarborough who don't believe in america
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis